you ever hear mike talk about the toad
yeah yeah which i've got to admit we
were even pre pre-show i was talking
with some of your producers about about
um you know mushrooms and stuff
i i i'm on mushrooms right now yeah
so as someone that's never done that how
does it open you because i've because
i've heard that it can be used to treat
treat uh mental illness and to treat
anxiety listen let me get
i don't even know how to um articulate
it so i'ma say i'm expressing like that
when you take the toad
you have to prepare not to be yourself
anymore you know you're gonna change
all right that's all i can tell you
if you like who you are right now and
stuff
you don't [ __ ] with this [ __ ] it's gonna
make you better but that's the fear part
you gotta go beautiful this is gonna
make you better listen you know what i'm
not in the body it'll take you it might
correct me if i'm wrong it'll take you
in a life roller culture listen
everything that's kind of happening
lost 110 pounds man the same [ __ ]
after that for somebody
wait so you mean so you mean the the
the one time that you did it no the
second time okay the second time you did
it yeah but but how long does it last it
lasts like um 20 minutes
that's it
in 20 minutes you want to get like 2 000
years of experience in your field
see that's some quantum [ __ ] yes
that's what i said articulate yes he
gets a compression of time listen you
can't articulate it you're gonna see it
you're gonna see your
great-great-grandmother you go listen
you're seeing the first you
you know there's gonna be chinese men
the first male you the first guy that
when this dick comes out your bloodline
the first one you gotta meet that person
you know why i can't do it and maybe
this is you know we're talking talk
about fear
i was raised
because i saw so many cats that i grew
up with
uh whether it was crack especially crack
crack at that point crack or whatever
it was drilled into me and i joke about
this on stage it's like there are so
many things i've wanted to try but in my
mom's head when you go and die so you
don't smoke drugs you're going to die so
i hear in my head but i hear about
mushrooms and i hear about these
experiences and i wanted to
to see just told that um
mushroom is not even a tenth of a
percent what this is
so when you talk about the toe you mean
the literal toad the yes what so it's
the sonoran so it's also known as the
bullfrog so what they do is uh
especially the sonoran toad that's up in
like northern mexico arizona
month of the year you could i've never
seen that but it stays underground 10
months out of the year
yeah so when it comes out so you have
two months to catch it and then extract
the venom from it and then you smoke the
venom but it really like
he doesn't mike doesn't see this stuff
as drugs like to us it's like it's over
50 times probably
never having the same [ __ ] experience
you're always scared see i don't get
scared anymore because i always want to
look at it so i'm getting ready to go
die cuz you feel like you die but i look
at it i'm getting ready to go reborn get
reborn yeah and do you remember the
trips that you have like like like the
things that you sometimes you don't but
then you see some [ __ ] that like whoa
you can't you might say hey it's over i
don't want to do this
but you're but you you got to go for the
ride you're on the ride not going to
stop that that's what i'm afraid of
because i don't want to give up control
listen you'll find out how powerful you
are once you give that up hmm yeah
listen
people think if
the little bit that people think you're
upping [ __ ] once you get this you'll
look at people different you'll look at
yourself different and your whole desire
your whole [ __ ] um it's like romney
is being successful it won't let you
make an ass out of yourself maybe sexual
or something as far as doing some stupid
[ __ ] going with the wrong people hanging
out with the wrong people you don't do
that no more
you've got me contemplating listening
what it is is is you know it's it's a
little different from everybody what it
is it's
kind of a psychology for you
like it shows you compassion bro it
shows you what really matters in life i
did it with mike about a year ago
and i was just like you know my trip was
different you know
mike's trip was different mine was like
man that brought me back to
when i was a baby like how my mom was
raised like it gives you it just gives
you the whole
answers
it'll be different for everybody man but
it's something that you got to be ready
for
and
you have to allow it to take you to the
thing you're going to fight it if i
would ever saw somebody do it before i
did i wouldn't do it
yeah once your ego died you don't know
what y'all know your
and plus
under um the toad
it's gonna feel like all your secrets
that if they knew they wouldn't be my
friend the feeling of it being exposed
mm-hmm that's like the image structure
they have
if i let them know this they gonna look
at me different
it won't explode but the feeling that
you would have that everyone knows it
gives you your weakest and your
strongest moments and at the end of the
game it's like to your god would it be
like this to mike it's almost like it
strips you naked and it teaches you like
naked like you know what i'm saying like
you're exposed but it's so beautiful man
because you're saying like oh my god i
did this this and that it's like
then you go back and look at the people
that that probably hurt you like this
this and that like you know what i'm
saying it's a trip it's it's you reach a
level of emotion whereas i hate and love
and everything in between how beautiful
everything is and all the time in 20
minutes i love it
all this is twenty find out the beauty
of death as well
in what way because um how could death
not be beautiful if life is beautiful
what did you exist for
you think god made life beautiful that
he was going to make
death not equally beautiful this is what
um
buddha
existence was
because he didn't understand people
applying self-suffering
um suffering he said some
that's not me for us humans are not
supposed to suffer
you know god didn't make anything here
for us to suffer but we put self-stuff
on it you want to i don't know we're
sociopaths
we're um that's and that's another word
what's that word when you're like
masochistic
most of us like massacres we like to
feel pain we want to take the poison and
wait for you to die
you know that's just some mentalities
that we have out here
some people just in love
and there's so much love they will have
a suicide pact with their mate
god i don't love you that much hey hey
hey
no
it's not that you don't love it that
much
it's just that your understanding of
love
is limited at that level well it's
skewed yeah yeah at that level but it
just keeps going he's just even myself a
certain level hey [ __ ] chill and it
keeps going for people who has different
thoughts and passions about love so if
you're able to
use use the toad or use mushrooms that's
something that i've definitely thought
about now especially when it comes to
fun ice cream
mental health that's fun mushrooms all
that stuff is fun
and remember too when mike talks about
the toe bro it's not like you don't
become an addict through it like you
really don't know no no no it's not like
you know
i mean i like doing it every day or
whatever but even you can even ask mike
like even right before he's getting
ready to do it like he fears it bro he's
scared not no more i used to be okay
because i looked at it as death and we
were able to die today because it was
like a ego death
and i look at it being reborn now
i'm going to be reborn today so you use
the shrooms today not the toad because
if you use the toe then you wouldn't be
able to have this conversation no i'll
be on under some [ __ ] but after i used
to 20 minutes later i'll be able to have
this conversation
wow you know sometimes i told you vomit
you throw up you scream you cry it just
puts you in so many different emotions
what's the uh the they they think that
the shaman used the awaska the oscars
they were good with me that wasn't it
with a negative perspective of it so it
didn't work good with me but it stuck
with me for a long time like a month to
stay to my sister i need to try it again
under different circumstances of mental
allowance you know i gotta give myself
up and not be an arrogant guy
and that's what it's all about your
um submission yes it's a great word it's
gonna make you cement so you bet you
might as well go in there already submit
right so don't fight i used to try to
fight it and then they showed that i
went in there like it was bad and then
they showed me some bad [ __ ]
and i realized i'm not a bad
[ __ ] and i just admit oh you
think you're bad [ __ ] gonna show you
some bad [ __ ]
you'll be screaming oh no oh they're
gonna show you there's some scary people
out there
are you scared of my son
no no you have to depend on the
mentality you go in there with right
right that's what it sounds like
i'll go in there with the
perspective you know i'm nothing god is
everything glory goes to god so you can
win that [ __ ] with the
confidence it's just something it's
gonna matter it's gonna show you your
first time that you're nothing you just
said that else back shows you you know
it'll strip do you do it with a purpose
like before something you go oh yeah go
go i'm gonna use this yeah to get to
that next state
like i'm getting ready to have this
exhibition and um
oh i'm totally on the toad
smoking
because it unlocks something in you
it's just uh explains to me who i really
am and i don't have to be a fake [ __ ]
you know it's even better it's just i'm
tuning into you it humbles you right
michael yeah it turns
and i used to say i'd be football i was
lying i didn't care what people would
say this is the first time my life i
don't give a [ __ ] they don't exist i
don't even see that [ __ ]
faith
well you've lived long enough and done
enough to earn that just for yourself i
learned that after i been involved with
all my stuff because it's
difficult to learn when you're going
through all that stuff
you know
wow
sit on it sit on it wait no but it's
funny that we're having this talk
because we we didn't even talk before
the show but i've had this recommended
to me
as a means of unlocking and and using it
in a therapeutic fashion and i was very
much on the fence because you know i've
been programmed to no i'm not going to
do some [ __ ] like that blah blah blah
you have to understand what you're told
right it's going to give you
understanding what it's like to be
the great one the universe you're gonna
feel it
you know you're gonna know you're part
of everything every person every race
every animal every tree every grass
every [ __ ]
every dump waste
with the beauty and
the so-called ugly but god made it all
so it can't be ugly it's just it's just
a limited understanding of it you know
all right
all right well if i decide to i'm gonna
let you know
because
because i can talk to you about the the
experience
when i first did i know i think let me
try it again
i know this thing i know what i used
though i didn't [ __ ] have money
mike gets a second dose bro let's try
that again
this is not right sun ain't right i need
to try this out this is [ __ ] [ __ ]
they did this on me they setting me up
so i had to take a look yeah
what type of environment did you do in
um i'm by myself with the sherman
i'm on the floor i also allow my wife to
come in
and
i feel very safe with her so um i'm
feeling safe with the charming too but
every experience
i experienced i experienced with my wife
so you got it you got you have to be
with uh
with with loved ones or people that are
close to you because you don't wanna you
don't wanna ruin the experience with
somebody that people probably bring [ __ ]
with them do you agree mike there's some
dudes that are so corrupt they're trying
to do this toad that you just can't be
around as crazy as that sounds dude yeah
no that's why
everything what's the environment [ __ ]
it's like a ceremony
[Music]
[Laughter]
ain't no ain't no hey [ __ ] let's
it sounds like that's what it is it
doesn't sound just like oh let's get
high it's
it's a purposeful key yes you can't even
pay for it so you had to always give
donations
you can't take money for it so you have
to say donation
you can't sell it
yeah bad old man can't sell it can't
exchange money for the total
maybe for charity of the toad that he
passes forward but your intention is
giving this money it's just for
donations and not for buying this
because this can't be bought it's not
supposed to be bought but wayne sit on
that wait and i just i'm gonna sit on
that for real as a five-time emmy award
winner is that is that surreal to you
man absolutely it's a real team
i never think the money unless it's a
donation isn't it creator what uh this
is skin this donation sends the sling
the the sly word to me take the money i
don't know it's just
it's just because you don't want the
karmic blow it's blowing it's possible
we're supposed to be called made this
was on a [ __ ] toad you can't sell
this [ __ ]
so
well well i'm not gonna ask you i was
gonna ask you because i was gonna ask
because a lot a lot of things will will
be stripped like even though like even
like the question that i asked you like
having the you know being a five time
emmy award winner that [ __ ] doesn't
matter man like it's a trip
nothing like nothing right mike yeah
like i don't walk around even thinking
about those things because i think that
that yeah like it's great when you've
achieved certain certain bench
benchmarks but at a certain point you
know in a certain age in a certain place
in your life it's about
yeah it's about your family you're
getting better too but it's still
getting [ __ ]
it's in you can't your family can't stop
it for me nothing go out put it in your
awards getting [ __ ] i'm a competitor of
life
because you got to be be a competitor
right
right i mean if you don't compete but
you you you knew that yeah you know that
already yeah man if you don't compete
where
where are you going to sit well there's
all these twigs the romans even the
ancient african they always allowed um
the kids to fight fight hard fight your
brother's heart punch him in the face
kick him fight hard because um they
didn't want you to give in on the
slightest struggle they wanted to have
some kind of game in you some kind of
thoroughbred lesson
because you have to life life itself is
a struggle and even listening to you
talk about toe guitar and everything
whatever the thing is that you use as a
tool
to help you
stay in the game and compete if it's
that to help your mental state so that
you could do all your [ __ ] listen this
is what listen this is listen
oh i can't even say that you can't tell
the toe what it's doing what you and me
with you know you just can't say i'll do
this if this is good enough the toe was
[ __ ] on you
the toe is god
that's what i'm trying to tell you this
is your closest
similar regard until you die
wow
you know you might see him but i can't
see him but i could feel
that's where you almost see him but you
feel the intensity of feeling the empath
that the toe gives you the feeling of
being an empath will blow your mind and
do you feel them each time your feelings
of divineness it humbles you
it just humbles you it doesn't even make
you think that you it gives you that
problem
but it humbles you to know that it's
that kind of power out there and you're
really nobody and i think i'm a bad
[ __ ] but all right y'all i'm
nobody i miss a piece of the puzzle
well anybody who thinks that they're bad
[ __ ] just like you were saying
it's it
no no you said god god given
you can have all that power to be the
baddest but it's not yours it didn't
come no from you right once you're
noticed by god
you noticed by the devil too
he can't know about you another guy
don't
right his job is to crush everything god
does so he got he he spotted this guy
well you know the saying right when
we're kids kids you know the devil is a
busy man oh man
but listen he's really not busy because
he's like the line he sends us the
minions out to cause [ __ ] he's he's not
he's chilling hanging out with god
talking some [ __ ] but he had this
opinion about doing chicago historians
about doing [ __ ] and with the best guard
with because if you're on your grind
then the demons are on that grind too
absolutely it's not that easy man it's
the
word i would look for the polarity
mm-hmm
if i don't have this bad [ __ ] the good
[ __ ] don't exist which i've never
thought about even when you talked about
death because i think i'm like like a
lot of folks i'll be honest i fear death
you you do everything in your power to
never you know we're all going to see it
in your life life is something to fear
you don't know when shit's going to
happen you know death you know
from your perspective it's just death
dude he's he's spot on that's
it's the ultimate improv show and death
is good that's eternal yeah
you know what i'm saying we die our
spirit's gonna go somewhere no but
definitely it's us at highest potential
wow
[Music]